hello everyone i'm alana and this is
david goldfaub who is the creative
director
that's true excellent nailed it uh at
the outsiders who recently released or
didn't release actually it's just a demo
uh metal hellsinger which has really
blown up the internet david how has that
been
uh
weird
um
i i think uh
it's been great um the people like you
know like the demo stuff it's also been
very strange because
uh i don't think we were like mentally
prepared for people to like it as much
as they seem to i'm just so surprised
that you keep saying that um yeah
i'm so surprised because
to me the surprising part it just seems
like such an obvious win like you paired
doom with a rhythm game in a way that i
haven't seen before
um and doom is already very loved for
the music
but you still have that gameplay down
too because it doesn't feel gimmicky uh
it just seems like such an obvious win
i'm i'm
surprised that you didn't think you
nailed it but then also with my limited
experience working in game development i
was saying this to you the other day i
have no idea of what i'm working on
how any of it would be received
that's kind of it's like we knew that it
was good we did a bunch of like internal
play tests um and you know like uh i'd
like to believe that we have a pretty
good compass when it comes to like
thinking you know knowing what we like
and i think people really liked it
internally but
you know we um knowing that
having that feeling internally and
that's
setting
sending it into the wild is like a whole
other thing so you really don't know um
and i've seen
i've seen it happen where people really
liked something internally and then it
just you know
it just [ __ ] didn't
go anywhere um so
we didn't
we hoped i hoped that people would
you know feel the same way but um really
it was it felt like we just had no no
clue how it was gonna be received so it
was so in that sense it was super great
um also personally like i'm very bad
with um positive feedback so i'm like oh
no
it's too much so i think
i'm better with critique
yeah but i imagine you've been watching
streams youtube like you've been
watching people playing and how has that
been
um super super cool uh i saw your stream
obviously i watched a bunch of like big
streamers i watched a bunch of smaller
streamers um i watched people that had
you know one viewer i just like to see
everybody and it's funny because i i
never watch streams like i don't know
anything about streaming really before
this i don't watch the video
i was like what's happening and so um
so that was kind of interesting too just
to see like oh this is actually
entertaining maybe i'm biased obviously
because it's our thing so i have a much
bigger investment but then i found that
i was still listening to people
not play my game after that so i was
like what's happening so it's a funny
way to be introduced to
twitch culture
is there anything that you've learned
about the game from watching people play
the demo now
they are better than we are because the
main one
um
i think
also i like i've seen some [ __ ] weird
stuff i saw one guy who is like
really not good at the game i'm not
going the name names quite a big
streamer
and uh and he was yelling like he seemed
to be into it but he was like yelling at
the top of his lungs and he was like
dodging forward for some reason trying
to keep keep the beat but he wasn't
doing it in like the right way he was
doing the wrong way and that was very
frustrating because yeah
but then there's people who are
um
like
michael michael jordan level athletes
when it comes to playing and um
we have really good players but i
haven't seen anybody capable of doing
some of the stuff that i've seen you
know we don't have people that can do
some of the crazy stuff that i've seen
um so that's cool too because you're
like oh it does mean that
that seems to work
um oh like you learn new strategies yeah
no way that's cool
yeah i mean i don't know if you've seen
any speedrunners but they're doing just
not so stuff
um
like chaining
slaughters uh finishers and doing like
flop basically flying
like doing soaring stuff across the
across the like arena spaces and stuff
yeah i knew you could do but i've never
seen anyone do it like the way they were
doing it and really it's like another
game almost watching that is super cool
uh how did you when you picked something
like this to be a demo which like i feel
like isn't that common these days that
people just release demos like this how
do you pick what level like how do you
pick what area how much thought went
into what you were actually going to
release publicly
uh man i think
i wish i'm trying to remember how we
just decided to do this um
i guess also how did you decide that you
were going to make a demo
yeah um well what happened was
we were making this game and i think
marketing um
said
we really should do a demo because
people
need to play the game
to understand why it's fun because you
can show it yeah
and um
it doesn't have the same impact of
playing it and while i like i knew this
was true but i was you know i've done
demos before and it's a huge amount of
work and it's usually a nightmare
scenario so i was like no i don't think
that's a great idea and they were like
no no we should do it
so this is like one of the times where
marketing was actually right um i mean
not at this place but it's just in
general my experiences that doesn't
always work out so uh so they you know i
think gradually i was converted and and
um i do
i believe that's true that um this game
in particular really needs
you gotta play it because it doesn't it
doesn't show the same way as when you
play it i mean you can't really grasp
yeah how it feels or how difficult it is
because in theory most gameplay that
would be released would be someone
playing it very well
you'd be like okay yeah i get it
like that that's always a challenge i
figure with vr
how do you market yeah games
because they always look terrible when
you when you show them and then you play
them and you're like oh i get it that
rule that's true maybe that's why i
don't like i never thought about that
maybe that's why i can't get into
into like vr at all it's because every
time i watch them i'm like all right so
i've got some hands
it looks bad it looks real bad i did a
single vr gameplay and the effort that
was required to record it as well and
then everyone's like this made me motion
sick it's just like [ __ ] it
no i mean i i get motion sick using vr
so that's the other reason
yeah but um it is i think that's part of
it but yeah what was your the rest of
your question uh how did you pick this
particular section for the demo
uh it felt it was early in the game um
it was an interesting map um
we thought alyssa's song would be would
be cool for people to hear um i mean
they're all great it was just really
like i don't know that one i think it's
basically
i don't even remember why but that i
think i was just like this feels like a
good map it's got some visual
visually distinct elements we don't want
to show late game stuff
so
we hadn't talked too much stuff it felt
like the right you know right right
place that makes sense
um you mentioned alyssa obviously on
this game are working with a bunch of
very incredible vocalists how did that
come about
i think it's a lisa now that i think
about it i want to say
i also assume melissa
it's fine
we're both going to apologize you're
very talented man
very good
extremely awesome um
so
uh the way that it oh god how did it
start um you sound like you've been
working on this for seven years
yeah it's three it's been so long three
three and change three is a long time
yeah it is especially given you know
everything that's happened um i i think
i wanna say
um it began with
me like talking to two feathers who are
the amazing
music team
um
and going like
man i just i don't like metal the metal
that i've heard in games it's cool i
just want to do the kind that i like
um
and
and you know having uh
i can't remember exactly how but i was
like it'd be really cool if we could
figure out how to you know have it
be a sound a certain way be heavy like
this have you know i would love to have
this like the type of vocals that i like
and um and they were like well we could
why don't we like try to
do that um
why don't we
uh
try to add a vocal tract
um with someone and then then
somehow they knew
um
i think it was nicholas's he's the
one of the two feathers uh he his mom
like knew mikastana who's the the
vocalist of doctor
that's so cool
and like whatever so he he was down to
do it and they put together this like
kind of beginning track
um
with uh with him
and as soon as i
heard it i was like okay that's gonna
work
and um so did they write the vocals did
you have to write any vocals
who did that
the way it works
they put together the i mean they're the
musicians so that they like do all their
arrangement and everything and i would
like they would ask me like hey
what is this you know what's the feel of
this level what is there are there
lyrics that you want and i would like
send them stuff and they would arrange
it and make it work so sometimes i
actually got some some stuff in there
that's cool
it's very cool especially when it's like
your people that you love singing like
you know
some some bar that it's like yours but
um i mean they did like you know
99.9999 a
million percent of the it's like i just
got a word in and some or a line in so
anyway so um
uh
yeah so they basically to go back to the
vocalist thing
we had a list and we kind of started to
look for people after that um and it was
a long
[ __ ] slog to get how did you explain
it to
vocalists i imagine um some of them are
gamers and i imagine some of them are
not
there's only explain to them what the
[ __ ] they're doing yeah so
this this is um
this fell on the on the on their
shoulders also um
but basically
they would present like
kind of like we we gave them some
material which is like this is what the
game is that kind of stuff and then they
would they would
contact them or their management usually
their management because you can't get
to the artist in most cases um
with like a hey this is what we're doing
here's um you know here's the game
here's like uh here's what we'd like you
to do which is you know sing sing vocals
on
uh
on a track that we're working on and
then if they were interested it would it
would like
they would be like okay well i want to
hear the song because they all want to
hear the song because nobody wants to
sing on something that they [ __ ] hate
and uh
and then in most cases they'd be like
i think in almost every case in fact uh
i'm trying to think this is anybody who
said no at that point
oh there's
well there's usually management problems
uh but anyway so so so whatever so so
that that's kind of what happened and
then you know once they said yes then we
would sort of move to the contract stuff
sometimes they would work on the song
even before that
um like surge did actually no way yeah
serge was just like i'm in and then the
gamer people i mean matt plays games uh
stunner play game plays games um i think
bjorn might um
and i think james dortmund does but i
just screamed doesn't
search doesn't he used to he said
um yeah he used to who the hell else
toddy no
um
i don't know
there's no i have to count now just done
that i think there's like nine
it's pretty impressive
yeah i mean the whole thing is
ridiculous and it got the funny thing is
that of course it gets easier and easier
is the
more and more people that you get so you
start out with one person and you're
like hey
can we sign you
and then you know by the time you like
now that we have serge and this whole
crazy roster it's much easier to get
other people to be like hey you want to
sing on this track this guy's doing it
yeah yeah so that's how it worked and i
think that was part of the plan
um you're getting implemented i've
already said this too but i already want
these songs on spotify
i understand how complicated that is
because it's such individual people tied
to like individual labels like tied to a
video game like that doesn't sound easy
like who even owns
any of this music really yes a mind
complicated it's really complicated but
i know believe me
if there is a way to make it work we
will figure out a way to make it work
yeah
it's just very like dealing with record
labels has to be
oh those stories
yeah they're not the easiest
notorious
managers
yeah it's true
everybody's protected themselves i guess
it just sucks for us because i i'm sure
people will figure it out on the sly and
i will be sure to not let you know about
it so that i'm not responsible for any
takedowns you didn't just say that
you're not aware of any of it happening
i did see that though and it's awesome
but it is like
it's not like like it's going to be a
thing where you're playing three levels
especially i feel like with speedrunners
you're going to learn a song and you're
going to want to hear a song more it's
going to be frustrating to only be able
to hear it the way that you should hear
uh
on an actual
album but i suppose that's very
complicated that's like i know that um
composing for games is complicated
anyway like i all my talks with austin
wintry about the amount of layering and
making sure things build up in time and
i think that was one thing that really
stood out is the vocals
slowly
coming down meant that i was [ __ ] up
it's so disappointing when you lose that
but at the same time it's not abrupt
like it's just such a such an
interesting balance and obviously such a
part of the game that like gets you
excited as it builds and then makes you
feel like [ __ ] about yourself as you
lose it well that's that was the goal
obviously
how can i make you feel terrible about
yourself appreciate that thank you
yeah no problem someone who doesn't
spend much time on the internet i need
more of that
but outside of the music i mean i know
the game isn't actually out yet just the
demo
it's like a bunch of questions i want to
ask um
i we kind of already touched on how the
idea came about to actually get
vocals involved but what about the
concept of the game itself where did it
where did it start
um it started when i was playing
i think well the
there's kind of like the thing that i
liked which it wasn't it wasn't like the
genesis of the the game but it was like
the seed maybe and that happened a long
time ago when i was playing vice city
and drive yeah do you remember my city
such a good game
uh
did you ever like drive on the beach
probably like just just like i wanna
know how old i was when i played by city
it's gonna make you feel bad about
yourself you're probably you're probably
like seven or something i think i was
like
12.
yeah okay no it's fine i'm old i've
accepted
i actually had a game breaking bug with
bikes by city vice city so i never
finished it i used to pull through the
map at a certain point it's devastating
but i probably did drive on a beach yes
so like i used to do this thing where i
would just [ __ ] cruise on the beach i
wouldn't even play the game i was just
like i was listening to music and
driving along such a good soundtrack
it's great it's such an awesome
soundtrack um
and so and i think it was i was probably
listening to one of the metal stations
and so like
maybe it was the motley crue track or
something and i was like this is cool i
like this and maybe it was
i don't even know if i was doing games
then i might have been like doing
interaction design but whatever i i was
like that's cool and i sort of filed it
away
until many years later
and then many years later uh i was
working on darkborn i think and doom
2016 had just come out
um and i liked the soundtrack a lot but
i actually found that i liked it more
when i was listening to
whatever music i was listening to so i
think i was listening to bleed by
meshuggah
and i was trying to i was killing stuff
and i was like
trying to sync my shots to the
nice
and um
but it just sort of happened i wasn't
thinking consciously about it i was just
like oh that's i like that that's cool
and then i told a friend of mine like um
you know
it would be nice to to be the demons
fighting or
be a demon fighting your way out of hell
but listening to
to this with like those kinds of
vocals and everything and he was like
yeah you should probably do that but
after this game i was like yeah maybe
maybe i will and then i forgot about it
how big is the team that you're working
with now that's it as an aside
how many people are working on this game
wow that's tiny 30 32 maybe
some outsourcers um but uh yeah
it's just a very small from i imagine um
battlefield bad company
speaking that company was like yeah i
think we were 90 maybe at peak and then
it's not even that many either
no but bc2 was pretty small but then bf3
was like 200
220 or something i love those games oh i
bad company i love them so much
yeah so good i like i like bc2 a lot bf3
i was so tired and burned out i think i
don't really sounds like most people
don't think that's just you anyway start
as an assignment um
yeah so then then like how does starting
the studio all come together and
you know
that the actual game being made
well i mean the thing is that we were
working on that other game you know um
we were working on darkborn which was
kind of the reason the studio was
founded and then for reasons that i will
be redacted
um
it didn't work out in the way that
sometimes stuff work doesn't work out
you know with the with the publisher
they canceled the project we had a very
limited amount of money and time to
survive
and uh and it was really like touch and
go for up until i mean we had like
whatever i think i told you but we had
like
maybe two months of of money like just
left so we were like should we close
should we not close
and then in the way that sometimes stuff
happens um
people that were interested in darkborn
but who couldn't get it for reasons
happened to be fun calm and they were
like is there anything else that you
would
you think you could do you know you
can't do this game you can't do a dark
warm
is there another idea and i was like oh
yeah well there's this
um
there's this metal thing that i've been
thinking about
and uh they're like that sounds
interesting the rhythm game and i was
like uh yeah yeah
and um
and then i think uh you know i went
i can't remember but i think i went to
was it dice no it was to gdc and i just
sort of pitched the
idea to them and they were like yeah
let's
let's do something and then that was
like a whole series of events but
eventually that's how we started working
on
i mean that's like feels like a
like pretty normal way to start working
on a game except that you had like
almost the whole studio closing down
right in between yeah terrifying
yeah and it actually even the it really
was like a whole
garbage experience uh which wound up
you know working out uh but man it was
uh it was definitely like i would not
recommend it to people uh who who want
like uh you know who think that
indie development is is good times um or
easy or any of that it was definitely
like oh no
especially when you have like people's
whole lives and food on their tables and
all that
resting on something succeeding that is
absolutely brutal but i mean yeah to
have come even this fall again game's
not even out yet
to the point where people are losing
their [ __ ] and are super excited about
it and everyone's hyping it up like i
feel like that's just such a beautiful
journey even despite the obviously very
stressful
parts in between
yeah i mean it really is i think that's
part of why it's so hard for
like me personally to internalize any of
the good stuff because i think i'm still
living through the
trauma of of uh and i think the whole
studio that was there like they remember
that stuff you know nobody left either
which is no way wow nobody [ __ ] left
like everybody's like [ __ ] you'll figure
it out and you know wow so that's gotta
feel pretty incredible everybody trust
you that much that's
i don't know why i really don't um i i
think you know
we have like just an amazing bunch of
people and um and for good for bad they
thought we would figure it out and um
somehow um you know
sometimes somehow we figured it out but
yeah i mean so much of it is luck too
you know we just i think we
i don't want to over attribute um
stuff everything is
any anything coming together with 30
completely different people
the scale the video games are and the
amount of time you have to put into them
is a whole lot of luck
nonsense that any game ever gets made
it's crazy i don't know how we keep
doing it here who was it i think it was
was it chris butcher somebody said
making a video game is like skiing ahead
of an avalanche
and it's like my favorite it's just
that's how it feels all all the time
yeah
the fire is never gone nothing has ever
calm yeah
yeah that's definitely a thing so
uh to jump to like some positive parts
about working on it of course again not
out so don't you you know
leak anything um what's your favorite
thing about the game just in general
what's your favorite thing about
it oh man that's tough
i mean
obviously like the soundtrack is a big
big thing for me but i i think
just i think getting into flow in the
game is my favorite is my favorite thing
um
because
it's so it's really hard for people to
understand why that that is meaning
feeling why that feels good yeah
meaningful and maybe like um
because i'm a
adhd person
achieving flow state is like a it's
especially rewarding for
for me i don't know um if that's true of
everybody
but it definitely feels like yeah this
is
i have peace i definitely felt that way
when i was playing especially like when
i just lost it for no reason
well then you just get mad i don't know
why i did that
yeah definitely happened a few times
well sorted yeah
i think it's that for me um
and for anyone who doesn't like metal do
you still feel like this is something
that you would recommend
yeah i mean based on the streams i've
watched so many people just be like look
i'm not a metal fan
and that they just say they open up they
open with that and they're like i'm not
gonna like this game and and then like
10 seconds whatever like 20 seconds and
they're like
you know that's pretty pretty good and
then like two minutes and they're like
okay this is kind of fire and then like
you know by like halfway through they're
just like where can i get the soundtrack
so i think
because they feel like they're a part of
it you know like i feel like when you
give someone the ability to feel like
they are a part of making metal music
they feel so [ __ ] cool that it's very
different to just listening to it
passively
yeah i i think so and that was kind of
my my hope with all of this was how do
we get people to enjoy it
the way that i enjoy it kaida
and feel like i used to feel playing
rock band where i'm like i'm doing that
you know like i'm playing the song that
i i love
for people um without being a musician
and um like that was my ambition i guess
was just like how do we how do we get
people to feel that good about you know
achieving
this state uh and then enjoying the
music and so if we even get like 10 of
it i think it's a win i feel like you're
on a pretty good path to get at least 10
percent
yeah i think you're all right and then
one of my other favorite questions to
ask people outside of like favorite
thing about it is what what do you think
has been
the most challenging thing about working
on this game the the thing that has
tested you the most is somebody has a
ton of experience oh god been in the
industry for a long time
i definitely think it's figuring out how
to do how like rhythm gameplay affects
the shooter
yeah gameplay i mean because you make a
bunch of assumptions like you mean i've
made shoes for a long time and you have
like a set of things that you know work
and you've got a set of things that you
know don't work and all of those things
go out the window when you add
rhythm so like a bunch of people have
made rhythm shooters i think harmonix
had one that failed um you know
yeah they it's called chroma i think
oh that does sound um
yeah and um
people that are like musicians way
smarter than i am you know like like
it's sort of so i think there's there's
like real problems with with the genre
and bpm made that campus really good
they had one solution to kind of how
how they were treating it um and
i didn't want to you know
i didn't really want to um
attack the problem from like a musical
place because that isn't really
a my domain and b
like um
we are a shooter first studio so it was
more about figuring out
for us and
like
how uh
how do you make sure that you don't lose
the shooter of it all
yeah but even like it just needs to
it needs to be um
i guess i was hoping that we could make
it so
it was
understandable to people and that they
they didn't feel like they needed um to
climb this immense mountain in order to
be able to play the game
um
and that meant
like when it comes to what's the most
difficult part it's like figuring out
okay so what are we gonna
which way are we gonna handle this
this this situation so
you know we had a lot of like really
complicated discussions about what about
how how do people register the rhythm
well what's the feedback on the rhythm
um should you be able to you know should
we force you to not shoot uh i mean if
you miss the beat do we you know do you
does the weapon not work
and like all of those things we we
favored the shooter direction rather
than the
other direction
because it's like that's what
felt best to us
it makes sense that those those were
hard uh those are
boss fights have got to be a very unique
thing to figure out
that team deserves like several medals
because
um they were also really really tough
yeah
it's very
i can't even imagine where you would
start i can't even imagine like knowing
what the people who design our boss
fights do how they would start if you
were like and you have to do it to music
to time i don't even know how you would
begin
it was a process is what i would say um
of the experimentation and like this
will maybe work and then you know
it's working no it's so exciting to see
somebody like
doing something that's so much of what
it is right it's just like finding
something new and figuring it out
everyone can make a
generalization i was going to say
everyone can make a shoot out that is
not true most people can't so just
kidding
people on the street right now going out
there making shooters point being you've
made something that challenged you more
than a shoe i mean
it's just it's it's definitely hard it's
making shooters just really hard making
yeah
a good like a shoe a rhythm shooter is
is harder
yeah because it's just so like you just
don't have the resources of even the
people to pull from who have the
experience having worked on that thing
okay yeah it's just now how it actually
is yes exactly
it's not to say that it's it's uh i mean
you know the folks that are making
destiny or
call of duty or battlefield or whatever
that's a
still solving problems but it's yeah
yeah just uh
yeah people don't have the answers to
pull from it's it's a lot and i
appreciate it and i'm very excited to
play it when is it coming out um
september 15th i'll take it
yeah
actually my mom's birthday
not a metal fan
you can get it for your mom i might do
that
here you go
she has a window surface pro um
it's not gonna go well
might not work great no not optimized
for the windows surface pro i mean maybe
it should be i'll suggest
yeah last year it was a 60th i got her a
tiffany bracelet because i couldn't go
home this year
it's hell singer
i mean that seems not as good to be
honest
listen for my mom probably not but it is
the kind of game i think she'd like
watching like my mom
watch me play loads of games my whole
family you do together
oh my god that would be so funny it'd be
like and last year we got to the tiffany
bracelet but this year and then you know
just you film it and she's just
horrified again on the windows stuff is
pro it'll be great i can't wait thank
you for
releasing the video game specifically on
my mom's birthday
really means a lot to our family
i'll let everybody know
uh is there anything else you would like
to add or anything else that you like
really want people to know about it um
other than i can leave a link in the
description to when people can play it
no i mean i think if if people you know
have if you like doom and you like
um metal and you like rhythm games then
you should
check it out and even if you don't you
should probably check it out it's free
let's see and it takes like 15 minutes
yeah got to play the game to know even
if you watch videos it's not going to
tell you
i strongly agree yeah when i when i put
my uh video together off of the stream i
intentionally did my first playthrough
and my last playthrough instead of the
whole thing because the difference
between the two was dramatic and i felt
like it was a really good way to show
the progression because at first i was
just so bad
and then as i slowly got better
literally every time moved up the
leaderboard it was like very very cool
to to see those back to back it was cool
so much faster and yeah it was
very very fun time playing it i have
played it since i'm not trying to get
the top 300 like andy cortez that's
insane
he's committed did he do it yet yeah he
was in houston's top top 300. i think
he's in the top
i think he's top 100
that's wild
yeah he was re i mean people
some people are just like that's it um
i'm going for it um which means that we
have to like rebalance
we have to there's a bunch of score
exploits that we have fixed but they're
not they're not live yet so
really only just told me that the way to
do it was to make sure that you didn't
get hit he's like
trying to take damage because i guess
that's the thing that i was allowing to
happen because it did occur to me that
that was so negative um it's like don't
take hits
yeah just try to to
make sure that you're on um using the
skull even when you're moving between i
was like okay good place to start good
place to start i think that's good
that's good
right now
whatever
top ten you can get the top ten easy i'm
sure it's basically top ten it's bots
now probably andy paid for bots probably
so
yeah what am i supposed to do
no i can't do anything
uh david where can people find you
what does that mean
usually people just tell me that twitter
but if you have like a link to twitter
yeah just talk to me on twitter that's
fine what's for twitter
oh
just like look for me and they just
they're wondering uh locust9 on on
twitter i'll also leave a link in the
description thank you so much for
sharing me today i hope you have a nice
morning it's midnight here it's 9am or
whatever there
thanks
you guys any time
okay specifically midnight
thank you bye